in this video we're going to be showing
exactly how to take an archicad model
into twin motion and then finally into
Photoshop all of these results are going
to mimic that of path tracing even
though the M1 Mac still doesn't have
that available to it it doesn't matter
if you're a complete beginner an
intermediate or an absolute professional
there's going to be some value in this
video here today for you what's going on
guys my name is David tomich I'm a
registered architect here in Western
Australia and without further Ado we're
going to turn around to this screen to
get started with today's tutorial so now
we have arcad 26 open in front of us and
we're going to start with a very simple
modeling exercise to be able to get
something into twin motion the image
that you see above me is going to be our
reference image I've gotten this
directly off Instagram I'll tag whoever
the person was here I'm just using it as
a very simple reference so what we're
going to do is start in arcad 26 we're
going to press command and seven button
to open up our story settings we're
going to start by introducing a few
additional stories so let's go ground
ceiling and also a second floor we then
want to introduce a roof above and our
footings below I'm going to go ahead and
change these story settings so pause the
video in a second and copy these into
your software and there we go pause that
introduce that into arcad and now press
Ok We're going to start with our wall
tool come across to our wall structure
and then we're going to select any of
our brickwork let's use the cavity 50mm
block brickwork if we zoom in we're
going to see we have a garage a small
what appears to be bedroom at the front
an entry and a room upstairs we're going
to very quickly Mass out these spaces so
looking at it we're going to have a 6x6
garage what you're going to see is we
have a rounded corner on one of these
sides so let's select two of these walls
fill it slash chamfer option and we're
going to fill it we're going to maybe do
about a meter and see if that's
approximately right that looks quite
good to me so we're going to keep it as
that so simplicity's sake I'm going to
highlight everything Ctrl or command M
whilst pressing the alt button mirror it
across command D and move it one meter
away I'm probably going to move it
another 500 mil just because that's a
little bit close and then I'm going to
select that bedroom and shift it out
approximately one and a half meters now
this bedroom appears to be significantly
taller so what I'm going to do is I'm
actually going to link that to our
second floor and then I'm going to
increase that another 200 millimeters
further I'm then simply going to mass
out a simple box at the back and
introduce our door somewhere
approximately in the middle between
these two spaces so that's going to be
our shape for the time being jumping
into door settings we're going to be
able to put our garage door in and our
front door in so if we jump ahead and
use the vertical sliding garage door 26
with the style 6 activated change out
model settings to a nicer color we're
just going to make them all white we'll
have to make the door significantly
bigger because it's way too small for
what we need it for so I've made that
garage door four and a half meters wide
next I'm going to Simply jump into the
settings again and find our front door
I'm simply going to use door 26 again
make it a plane door and paint it all
white right in the middle here I'm then
going to select all of my walls straight
away open up those settings and change
this to a white brick so white neutral
brickwork and press OK again if we jump
into 3D let's see how much we've created
already we've very quickly and very
rapidly created the foundations of this
entire project so I'm going to copy the
settings across those walls to reduce
the height link all our brickwork
settings so it actually comes out
properly and now looking at this image
it appears this garage wall is
definitely linked to our second floor so
let's increase the height of that and
let's increase the height of that size
as well and there we've started to
produce something that looks quite
similar to what we see in this render
now the most important thing about
architectural renders is the details so
what you see up the top is we have a
flashing for the roof on all of these
parapets so what I'm going to do is
quickly introduce a slab that goes on
top of all of these about 50 mil deep
and painted titanium whites coming back
to our ground floor plan simply
selecting our slab tool selecting the
outside selecting that slab and reducing
it from the inside we rapidly form the
shape we need if I open up the settings
make it generic 50mm let's paint it
glossy white in this instance actually
because it's going to be a metal rather
than anything else we're going to
increase that to 5 meters just so I can
see it directly in 3D and find it
quickly and then command D to drop that
down on top of our brickwork there we go
we have our metal flashings on both our
paraple walls I am actually going to
paint this titanium white instead of the
brickwork because it does appear in the
image that it is rather white next we're
going to jump to our second floor and
create this upper bedroom right clicking
on our ground floor to show us Trace so
we can see what's happening below take
that same brick object and then simply
drawing a shape that suits the overall
project design so for me it probably
looks something like that and of course
we want to curve that edge again to a
meter selecting all those walls let's
increase their height to the roof and
let's increase that another 750 mil
because it is quite tall in this
instance now we again want to select
those walls we want to decrease that 257
mil which is the height of our slab
below and we want to push it Forward
probably about another meter and a half
then we create our Portico into our
entry an important step what we want to
do now in our cloud is see how these
materials don't align what we want to do
is select all of our walls with
brickwork come up to document creative
imaging align 3D textures set origin now
we can set the origin from anywhere as
long as it is consistent so I'm simply
just going to pick that point there on
the project and you'll see all of our
brickwork has immediately aligned now
let's jump back into our ground floor
plan select a window that works for the
front and top let's use variable window
26 untick upper and lower transom so we
only have the side light active we're
going to turn that in to a top hung and
we're obviously going to paint
everything black so saying okay let's
drop that window into our space and then
adjust it to the size we see fit
personally I think that's probably about
two and a half meters wide by two and a
half meters tall roughly centered into
the room so if we come back into our 3D
model maybe I've overkilled that quite a
little bit so let's make that two meters
tall
and two meters wide dropping it down
approximately in the middle of the
project using our slab tool we can then
create the actual window box quite
easily so to grab the slab tool simply
draw a 450 deep slab change the settings
so it's only 10 mil thick and paint it
black we can repeat that process for the
entire window all the way around jumping
back to our ground floor plan let's copy
this window move upstairs and replicate
it above as well now that we have the
window above it is slightly smaller so
let's make that 1500 and raise the
window higher in the picture and copy
our window box up the top as well and
there we go we have the predominant
start and shape of our actual building
it's probably a little bit wider than
what we see here on the image on the
left so if you wanted to shrink it down
and make it a bit more proportioned you
definitely could but we have the generic
shape last but not least I'm going to
introduce the flashing on the top of
this parapet and then we're going to
make a quick start on the ground below
okay so we have a flashing at the top we
can start making our ground so let's
start by using the mesh tool we're going
to start at the actual door so drawing a
simple square and changing our settings
it appears that they're using some sort
of stone work so let's use Stone 12 in
this instance let's come back out here
let's then extend that further out drop
that 100 Mil and extend that all the way
out here what I will do is adjust the
nodes 300 mil to the right hand side so
I can start creating a curved pattern
come back down into our ground floor
plan take our polyline tool and simply
zigzag a crazy Stone pattern cut out
into the actual texture so now that we
have a bit more of a jagged edge we're
going to get more of a realistic look
for that crazy Stone we're then again
going to create a very simple driveway
dead straight from that change our
material to Asphalt dark press OK and
then introduce a gray and overall to the
actual project okay now we have our
model completed in a number of minutes
and we can take this in to Twin motion
now if you're an arcad user you may or
may not have noticed this desk map
behind me this desk mat showcases all of
our cad's features shortcuts and
everything that you need to know to make
sure you improve your workflow it is
available in the description down below
so grab yours today for both PC and Mac
so now that we have it into twin motion
we're going to focus on the One camera
angle in particular we're going to set
up that camera angle perfect so we don't
have to worry about anything else let's
come into media image let's create our
first image next we're going to tap on
more and the first thing I'm going to
adjust is the actual format this looks
like an Instagram format let's go 2000
wide by 2500 high for the Instagram
format next we're going to come a little
bit closer in adjust it how we want to
see fit change our camera angle I
personally like about a 50 millimeter
lens because that is the most natural to
the eye but what you'll notice is we
need to extend our ground floor can
quickly do that in archicad and come
back to Twin motion very very rapidly we
then align perfectly to where we want to
see our project we can save our render
view what you will notice is the scene
itself is not at all light right so
let's change our Dynamic lighting to a
hdri sky and let's find a cloudy sky
that we like a little bit better so I
prefer the overcast Sky 24 in this
instance we're going to increase the
intensity of the sky to really blow that
Sky out as much as possible turn our
smog off back back to our lighting and
manually adjust our exposure now this
bit is what is very critical because if
you don't manually adjust your exposure
it's not really going to complement the
overall saying for me I want it to be
light bright and I want it to be quite
Overexposed in a natural instance I also
want to bring my white balance down to
really bring those white colors out
against the harshness of the yellow sun
so let's make it about 6200 we can then
increase our Ambience to one because
again we are looking for those white
colors of the actual brick texture now
we can come into our library and start
adjusting the materials so starting with
glass let's introduce a reflective glass
Metals we can do our brushed aluminum
for the metal framing of the windows
turn that to Black and increase the
reflectiveness now we can also go into
our Mega scans library to be able to get
a better Stone texture for the actual
crazy Stone so let's use something like
a flagstone floor on this crazy stone
that we have in front of us it's a
little blue again but we can fix that
and post if we need to we can also find
our concrete for that actual driveway
now we can use rough asphalt for the
driveway to give it that nice textured
look that we're looking for increase the
size as we see fit and then introduce
some Earth and a quick couple plants and
there we go now that we've added a few
little plants in between here some
leaves on the ground and two trees into
our scene we have something that
resembles what we're looking to create
the final steps obviously because we
don't have Road tracing is taking this
image into Photoshop so let's export
this image out and take it into
Photoshop so straight away edit it out
we have a really good image to start
with what we want to do is go into
Google and find a background street that
we can basically copy and paste in to
our mirrors so on Google we just want to
find a Suburban streetscape it doesn't
really matter what it looks like this
one's pretty good the sky is horrible so
we'll change that Sky to match something
more of what we have so Photoshop edit
Sky replacement and then we want to find
a very overcast sky in this let's accept
that Sky replacement merge those
together and overlay that in to our
actual window so now if I reduce my
opacity down to about 30 40 I can see
what we're using and how we're creating
that reflection so if we make that
reflection look something like that we
can then crop out the actual window
glass from the window frame delete the
rest of the image that we don't need and
you can see that we have a reflection
very quickly activated I also then want
to copy and paste some of our sky over
into our secondary window and repeat
that same process and now that we've
introduced this Ray tracing look-alike
we can merge our file come to image at
the top adjustments brightness and
contrast adjust our contrast a little
bit decrease our brightness as we see
fit and again repeat that step for our
curves and we can introduce our s-curve
into this project to make it stand out a
little bit more finally we want to
remove that blue as well so if we go
into Hue and saturation go into our
Master go to our blues and our Scions we
can decrease the blues entirely and
decrease our science as well to make
that more of a stone texture that we're
looking for we can decrease or increase
the lightness
and finally press OK anyway that's all
for me today guys thank you so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed the video if
you did make sure you check out the
playlist to the side of me for more
great architectural content if you loved
it make sure you hit that like button
and the Subscribe button but like always
I'll see you next Monday